Oh my God hi I love you thank you starting
you into Mr Wayne no please don't
so you're saying you could travel back in time
good Bruce I can fix things I can save people
save my mom save your parents
you can also destroy everything
I love you too so how was it this
week how's school school was good
oh this is mad trippy dude this is catastrophic
this world must die
I'm not gonna lose there again
That's not Clark my name is Kara I will help
you interesting groups want some help
wait he's Batman you want
to get nuts let's get nuts
this rips!
we try not to die
are you ready ready let's go
you have fancy friends
it was an Uber...Exec.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie they just
released a new Flash trailer so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos also do
a giveaway for movie tickets all you have to do
is enter is be a subscriber and just leave your
favorite moment from all the trailers on the
video this is also very apropos because they
released this like the night before the final
episode of The Flash TV show that's right as of
me posting this video Tonight is the last episode
of The Flash TV show so I'll do a separate video
for that later this week after it comes out
I know there's all kinds of theories about
cameos from The Flash TV show in The Flash movie
we'll see who winds up making it there are a lot
of rumors about that I'll talk about that later
in the video but there's a whole bunch of new
scenes during this so there's a funny scene with
Alfred helping them during one of Batman saves in
Gotham proving that Alfred is in the movie they
even go back to the original Batcave or part of
the Batcave the warehouse from Justice League
where he kept his ship and this is meant to be
taking place after Batman gives the Flash The
Flash ring with his new suit in it like he's
getting excited to go help Batman with his save
but then get stopped with the fans who are Star
Struck this is all taking place after the events
of the Justice League movie so people know that
the Justice League exists even Amanda Waller has
referenced the Justice League in previous movies
so they've become general knowledge like all the
Shazam characters the shazamly are big Fanboys and
fangirls of the Justice League and they just had
the funny moment with him getting awkward with his
fans and Alfred patching him through to Batman
and Batman getting pissed off like I need you
here five minutes ago I believe that Wonder Woman
is also supposed to be in this movie too at some
point during one of these saves like this big
bridge saved you see across the entire trailer
this happening earlier in the movie Ben Affleck
did say that they filmed a Wonder Woman scene so
hopefully that's still in the movie because
the way he talks about it sounds like it was
actually pretty solid he also jokes about how
it's some of the best scenes that he's done as
his version of Batman in any DC movie so far and
it's my best [__] I've done I finally figured
out how to play the game no really I got it
for real I was like hold on am I is that I
quit I know I quit and I know I came back but
I got it now but it was a it was a scene where
I got I get caught I get saved by Wonder Woman
yeah uh during a a conflagration with some some
some bad guys you saved me with the lasso of
Truth yeah and so what happens is that Batman
um divulges you know some of his real feelings
yeah about um his life and his work and uh it
helps you see the character and now you want
another chance to play it I was like wait a minute
I got it am I still with cannot guys we're still
rolling can we write another story where am I we
get a much longer scene of him fighting on the
bridge being way more dexterous like we saw during
the warehouse scene in Batman v Superman which
was probably one of the best Batman fight scenes
that we've seen in any movie so far just because
special effects have gone to the place where it's
a lot easier for them to show you what comic book
Batman fighting style is like like they can depict
him in a much more comic book Accurate Way which
they also use for Michael Keaton's Batman because
now they have modern technology which they didn't
have when they were were filming the Batman 1989
movie and Batman Returns there are also a couple
new scenes that aren't in the trailer of The
Flash in the middle of the day with this is Patty
spivot in Albert Desmond both of those characters
appeared on The Flash TV show in earlier Seasons
Chantel van santen played a version of Patty's
pivot in season two in the comics she starts
as a lab assistant at the Central City Police
Department where Barry worked in the future she
becomes a version of Hot Pursuit taking the gear
on the show she was more of like a regular
police officer who transfers in and becomes
a second love interest for Barry for a little
while and the funny thing is that Chantel van
santen said there was a bunch more storyline for
her character but the flash showrunner at the time
didn't like that she was actually doing other TV
shows and basically wrote her character off the
show earlier than she was supposed to leave I'm
not totally sure what they had planned for her I
think they just had more storyline with Barry
Albert Desmond was played by Tom Felton during
the savitar storyline most people remember him
as Draco Malfoy from the Harry Potter movies in
the comics he becomes a version of Dr Alchemy the
villain it's pretty much what they did with him on
The Flash TV show as part of this Avatar storyline
in the comics he suffers from dissociative
identity disorder and that's how he develops the
Dr Alchemy Persona that leads to Crime there are
a couple more Iris West scenes too I don't think
she's in a ton of the movie I think she's in a
little bit of it but it's way more than she was
in the Justice League Snyder cut and just setting
up their relationship a little bit more I don't
think there are together yet during the events
of this movie and I don't think that she's yet
realized that he is The Flash because they make
that big joke about his fancy Uber and she doesn't
immediately recognize that it's Bruce Wayne's car
but I do think the idea is that they've gotten to
know each other a little bit more since he saved
her during the events of the Justice League
Snyder cut they have the new scene of flash
trying to sell Batman on the idea of changing the
past by saying that he can save his parents and
Batman trying to explain to him why he should not
do that why it's a bad idea because his pain over
their loss is what drove him to become Batman
in the first place and do all the good things
that he's done in Gotham even during the events of
the Justice League movie Saving Thomas and Martha
Wayne in the past would prevent all that good from
happening and because we're doing a version of
Flashpoint in this movie even though it's a vastly
different version of Flashpoint in the comic book
version of that that winds up leading to Bruce
dying instead Thomas Wayne becoming the version
of Batman and his mother Martha Wayne becoming
a version of The Joker and it's just meant to
be an example of why Flash's mother also needs
to die in order for him to eventually become the
Flash and do all the good things that he did what
happens with Zod in the movie is a good example of
why it's bad when he messes with that because he
prevents metahumans from arising then they use the
Pink Floyd song it's time from Dark Side of the
Moon which is very apropos because it's a time
travel movie and the song cues in just as Batman
says he could destroy the timeline by messing with
it there's a bunch of new scenes with the adult
flash with his mother in the past and it seems
like it's when he travels back in time the first
time to save her and he starts interacting with
her like oh I haven't seen you in so long but
he pretends to be his younger self so that she
doesn't suspect something is up they had the funny
scene of him seeing his younger self also arriving
at home and freaking out having to tell him what's
going on why he's back there and I think part of
the idea here because it does seem like he loses
his powers like he does in the flashpoint comic
book and the flashpoint movie when it goes back
in time it's before he had the initial accident
the Central City Police Department that gave him
powers in the first place so he gives his younger
self Powers but something happens during that
and he loses his his powers while the younger
self gets Powers so he has to find a way to give
himself Powers again which is kind of what happens
in the flashpoint movie in the flashpoint Comics
originally the reason he lost Powers is because
when he saved his mother he prevented himself
from becoming the flash so they were just using
time travel in a slightly different way during
that storyline so you see all these scenes of him
trying to shock himself again give himself Powers
again recreate the accident and just like in
the flashpoint comics in the flashpoint movie it
doesn't work the first time and that's why you see
all this Blood while his body looks so messed up
and burned after which we see Supergirl carrying
him into this guy like she flies him up into the
sky into these clouds to be shocked by lightning
again and then it finally Works he gets his powers
back and I think that's why the color of his
lightning changes to a more reddish gold color and
the younger self has the blue looking lightning
that he has at the beginning of the movie The
other reason for giving them different colors of
lightning is so that you can tell them apart when
they're on screen and I think that'll be important
for the dark flash which is like a third version
of this younger Barry Allen in the movie so there
are a couple different flashes like there's the
younger Berry there's the normal older version
of berry but then there's the Dark flash which is
like an evil future version of this younger Berry
so they just want casual viewers who aren't super
familiar with the flash characters to be able to
tell the different characters apart when they're
finding on screen using their powers together I
think part of the idea with Flash versus the dark
version of flash gets into the hole Back to the
Future themes of the movie like there's a lot of
vibes from the back to the future movies in this
where you have dark flash being like an alternate
evil future version who's pissed off at the normal
version of Barry because of what's happening
during the movie and them not being able to fix
everything which I think this scene is all about
where you see the younger Barry yelling at the
older Barry saying that nobody has to die no we
have to find a way to fix this and the older bear
is saying no we can't fix this where they keep
trying to go back into the past like they pull
Flashpoint the first time when Barry goes back to
save his mother and then things just keep getting
worse and he keeps trying to go back multiple
times but event eventually he starts running
into fixed points in time that he can't change
and people wind up dying that he's trying to
save no matter what there's also the scene later
where it seems way more chill they're on the city
street you see all the people around them pulling
their phones out to record them that might be from
one of the original endings of the movie there
was a bunch of footage that everybody saw like
a year ago it was a long time ago where you see
Supergirl and Michael Keaton's Batman showing up
on the courthouse steps after he's found a way to
free his father from prison and clear him for the
death of his mother but I think what they've done
is that since James Gunn was hired by DC they've
changed the end of the movie to be a little more
ambiguous because in the original end of the movie
and I'm sure I'll talk about this after I actually
see the movie and we find out what actually wound
up happening in the original version when he goes
back to his normal Justice League Earth he also
changes things just a little bit so that at the
end of the movie when someone steps out of that
special car the Batman owes the special Mercedes
it winds up being Michael Keaton's Batman instead
of the Ben Affleck Batman and Supergirl winds
up being there instead of Henry Cavill Superman
so even though he re-fixes his mother's death
like his mother winds up dying and he winds up
saving the future he still changes things just a
little bit and I think that's how they originally
planned on explaining that Michael Keaton would
be sort of like the temporary crossover Justice
League Batman until they recast another version
but then James Gunn was hired and he developed
this new 10-year plan Batman brave in The Bold
and they're gonna recast a new version of Batman
in that movie so I think they changed the end of
The Flash movie and now it's way more ambiguous
about who that Batman winds up being at the end
of the film I'm supposed to see the movie in the
next couple of days so I'll post my non-spoiler
review as soon as they let us but like I said the
final episode of The Flash TV show is also like
literally tonight as I'm posting this video so my
video for that will also post by Thursday they're
basically closing out the show by having the flash
fight all of his former biggest villains like the
Harrison Wells reverse flashes back Zoom is back
there's also a rumor about Teddy Sears having a
cameo in The Flash movie instead of Grant Gustin
we'll see if that winds up happening sabotage
cards back God speed is back and they turned
Eddie Thon into a version of cobalt blue from
the comics which was a fan Theory all the way
from the flash season one we'll see how they wind
up ending things so my video for that should post
the next couple of days you can click here to
catch up with that and click here for my brand
new secret Invasion Marvel trailer video with
a whole bunch of Easter eggs with the Avengers
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!